j'ai vu qu'il y avait un communiqué la
mise en cause voilà près de se retirer
si on vous dira que l'icône rica a toute
la confiance de la commission éthique
puisque nous avons investi avec plus de
glisse
sa mort est pour elle a été investie
parmi les premiers
pourquoi lire ici parce que nikon madame
briques des compétences qui sont bien
évidemment personne n'est indispensable
mais elle a des compétences évidente à
la commission des finances
et nous avons à mesure les compétences
nous en avons besoin
nous avons absolument besoin d'avoir les
gens solides c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que nous avons investi comme la brique
[Musique]
le coach et richard et monsieur richard
chrétiens
parce que fonctionnaire à la commission
des finances et il faut tenir a demandé
m
et ce sont des gens incompétents servi
par tous donc
et j'espère encore que peut-être
génération sa décision mais si c'était
pas le cas et je respecte
je respecte ça mais nous respecterons la
condition d'aller séduire sa décision